on a tous signé pour la même chose pour
la même devise solo période
[Musique]
même si on ne les connaît pas ça reste
des collègues ils ont le même uniforme
que nous les mêmes convictions que nous
du coup c'est un devoir
et c'est un devoir d'aller d'aller à
leur cérémonie de la rentrée une
dernière formage ce sera mes bras une
dernière fois parce que du coup tous les
lundis matin à l'appel des morts aux
fruits seront cités relevé des couleurs
après le genre de la marseillaise
on cite tous les noms des
sapeurs-pompiers mans au feu c'est
quelque chose qui est important pour
tout le monde
ne pas oublier que certains données ont
été jusqu'au bout de leur mission ce qui
force le respect
énormément de respect
[Musique]
lorsqu'il ya eu accident rue de trévise
les collègues ont continué leur mission
parce que oui on a des
pertes mais il ya un fait éteindre il ya
des gens à les sauver donc il la mission
continue on continue à faire notre
travail malgré tout ça
[Musique]
j'étais dans mon collège et il ya eu un
flyer sur les jeunes sapeurs-pompiers de
mon village et à ce moment là je me suis
dit pourquoi pas aller voir je me suis
inscrit et j'ai totalement derrière
a tous je me retrouvais en fait
demandant dans les valeurs qui avaient
l'esprit de corps l'esprit de famille
la discipline toutes ces choses là qui
m'ont limitée du quai durant cette
partie de 12 à 18 ans qui peut être une
partie difficile pour tout le monde
toute ma vie après c'était je me suis
dit je sais faire que ça intervention
qui m'a le plus marqué en fusillade
on arrive jeune est décédé
la famille l'apprend et dans la rue
c'est quelque chose de très
très dur émotionnellement je suis
vraiment très très heureux ils ont fait
plein de choses
on y apprend beaucoup sur soi même il
faut y aller il faut y aller parce que
c'est un très très beau métier
[Musique]